você acredita que todos podem aprender
você acredita que você pode empreender
imagens ou pessoas vem à sua cabeça
quando você pensa empreendedores
por muito tempo as imagens que vinham à
minha mente eram essas aqui é muito
fácil associar empreendedorismo aos
grandes nomes
é muito fácil obviamente a social
empreendedorismo aos grandes homens e
mulheres que transformaram o mundo e
transformar a economia que realizaram
seus sonhos em grande estilo
e aí eu me dei conta que não era só eu
que pensava assim
o google também pensava assim se você
entrar no google agora e digitar a
palavra empreendedor e buscar imagens é
isso que você vai encontrar você vai
encontrar homens brancos de terno e
gravata muito confiantes e bem sucedidos
que sabem o que querem
aí eu pensei bom se o google sabe tudo e
ele sempre está certo então deve ser
assim mesmo será na universidade não foi
muito diferente essas imagens foram
sendo reforçadas na minha mente
só que por incrível que pareça foi nesse
mesmo lugar que o mundo mudou ea minha
visão também nesse lugar eu tive o
privilégio ea honra de conhecer pessoas
que mudaram a minha visão de mundo
tive o privilégio de trabalhar numa
empresa júnior onde eu conheci
empreendedores fora da caixa
pessoas que me desafiaram e eles me
ensinaram empreendedorismo com outros
olhos
eu aprendi que no brasil a gente tem
cerca de 45 milhões de empreendedores
deixe só e apenas 99% são micro e
pequenos pouco mais da metade são
mulheres e estes micro e pequenos
empreendedores são responsáveis por 85
por cento da geração líquida de empregos
no país
estima se que ainda temos no brasil mais
de 15
milhões de empreendedores na economia
informal e foi assim então que as
imagens na minha mente começaram a mudar
e essas pessoas incríveis começaram a
ensinar que o empreendedorismo é um
pouco diferente do que imaginava e que
não era feito de poucas fotos era feito
de um mosaico de micro pedacinhos era
feito de micro empreendedores que
construir a nossa nação
pessoas de todos os cantos do brasil
de todas as origens de todas as raças de
todas as classes sociais e todas as
cores em homens e mulheres que
empreendem que se desafiam que batalham
todos os dias para transformar sua vida
à vida das pessoas à sua volta à vida
das suas famílias e das suas comunidades
empreendedores que enfrentam muitas
barreiras externas e internas enfrentam
as barreiras muitas vezes não ter acesso
a crédito e não ter acesso ao
conhecimento formal de não ter acesso
uma capacitação simples pra aprender a
gerenciar seu negócio de não ter acesso
a uma rede a mercados
mas mais grave do que isso eles
enfrentam as próprias barreiras de não
se sentirem não se verem empreendedores
não se sentirem confiantes empoderadas o
suficiente para dizer eu sou um
empreendedor e eu vou buscar uma
formação eu vou buscar me capacitar
entender como funciona isso aqui que eu
tenho é um negócio
vou fazer e acontecer vou fazer ele
crescer
só que não essas são as barreiras que
eles encontram um dia após dia e mesmo
assim continuam lutando e continuam
brilhando e aí a gente se deparou com
outro dado tão revelador quanto uma
nação como a nossa
nós somos a sétima economia mundial e
somos o oitavo lugar em desigualdade
social
proporcionalmente a nossa riqueza
proporcionar nossa desigualdade
conhecimento
sete jovens com 19 20 e 21 anos
decidiram que a gente podia unir o útil
ao agradável e começar a empreender algo
que pudesse quebrar essas barreiras
assim nasceu em 2005 aliança
empreendedora junto com essas pessoas
incríveis que eu comentei lá que mudar a
minha vida
uma delas está aqui lá no fundo heleno é
uma idéia muito simples de que todos
podem aprender e de que o
empreendedorismo é uma ferramenta
extremamente poderosa para inclusão
econômica e social
a aliança trabalho viabilizando conexões
e pontes
nosso trabalho é conectar esse
empreendedor com que ele precisa para
crescer não só com serviços externos
crédito mentoria mercado mas
principalmente conectando ele com ele
mesmo conhece empoderando crescendo
incentivando que ele confie nele mesmo e
assim gerando transformação
empreendedores em poder anos depois de
10 anos todos entrando estão na tela
foram apoiados pela aliança depois de
dez anos são mais de 20 empreendedores
apoiadas diretamente e outros milhares
indiretamente a gente teve a honra eo
privilégio de conhecer uma série de
histórias incríveis que nos enchem de
humildade e nos provam todos os dias
empreender é possível uma delas a
história da dona e leite
a zona leste com 50 anos foi parar no
assentamento do movimento sem terra e lá
mudou a vida de muita gente
ela decidiu que ela não ia deixar que as
crianças daquele assentamento passem
pelo mesmo sofrimento que ela passou
então ela montou a primeira creche
dentro do assentamento e pelo seu
empreendedorismo hoje duas creches
municipais da cidade leva o nome dela e
ela não parou por aí
ela também empreendeu para as mães da
comunidade para gerar renda
pesquisou produtos orgânicos pesquisa
sobre a ecologia montou o grupo maria da
terra que hoje gera renda para 10
mulheres nessa comunidade e já tem
provocado transformações em vários
grupos produtivos na sua comunidade
outra história que eu amo de paixão
história do ad o edson com 21 anos
decidiu que estava cansado de ouvir as
reclamações dos seus amigos que falavam
que na comunidade deles não tinha nada
eles moram num é ele mora no interior
numa cidadezinha bem pequenininha na
região metropolitana de curitiba num
bairro muito isolado e ele decidiu que
não ia ficar ouvindo reclamação ele fez
uma lista das reclamações o que ele
chama lista dos não tem saiu do seu
trabalho
pegou o dinheirinho montou uma lojinha
onde ele providenciou e ofereceu acesso
á a nota à lan house loja de roupa
locadora sorveteria é crédito de celular
correspondente bancário xerox e acesso à
internet já falei bom ele chamou seu
empreendimento de é de modas e lan house
porque tem tudo haver certo
eu sou muito focada só que o edge
o edson é incrível é de entendeu que o
propósito dele era muito maior do que só
levar uma série de serviço ele precisava
transformar a comunidade dele o que ele
fez não chegava internet na comunidade
dele então ele fez um acordo com a
agência de uma empresa de energia
elétrica do paraná levou fibra ótica
levantou mantena saindo da cozinha dele
e ele fornece internet para toda a
comunidade dele tem mais de 300 clientes
você pode imaginar que até aqui a gente
estava mais do que convencido de que
todos podem aprender mas ainda faltava
alguma coisa faltar um elo perdido e
cielo chegou a romã e cielo chegou em
2012 para nós
em 2012 a gente se deparou com uma prova
científica de que todos podem aprender
esta moça na tela chamas as vacas é uma
professora indiana que fez da sua tese
de pós doutorado
ela queria entender o que faz do
empreendedor empreendedor e ela
descobriu coisas muito interessantes na
sua pesquisa
ela descobriu que não existe uma lista
um grupo de características ou traços de
personalidade que fazem de um
empreendedor que fazem o empreendedor
ela descobriu sim que existe uma série
de ações que faz um empreendedor
ela descobriu que todos os
empreendedores de sucesso que ela
entrevistou começaram com as mesmas
coisas com quem eles eram com que eles
sabiam e com que eles conheciam
começaram com que eles tinham
ela descobriu que empreender tem a ver
com errar e aprender com os erros
ela descobriu que empreender é sobre ter
incertezas e não certezas que empreender
principalmente
sobre amar o que faz e assim quando a
gente menos percebe já está empreendendo
quando - percebi eu me tornar
empreendedor acredita
comece todos podem aprender